foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
once upon a time then roses the most
Magical Kingdom founded by a king with
the power to grant wishes you are the
handsomest most beloved King you're
right I am a handsome king I'm so
nervous I think I'm going to explode my
best friend the king's Apprentice oh my
mouth trooping I feel like you're stupid
Asha come with me
Go Frozen wow people give their wishes
to me and I read the wishes I am sure
are good for Roses some of these will
never be granted that's
um most they deserve more than I decide
what everyone deserves
[Music]
so I look up at the stars to guide me I
wish and throw caution to every warning
sign
oh you spoil us with your magic I didn't
do it what
last night I made a wish on a star
uh and a star answered
foreign
who knew my voice would be this low I
believe I've just been threatened who
would dare threaten you
I have no response to that
there is a traitor amongst us find us
a dead end with unsanded mahogany
oh good Vine Valentino my butt found it
started this
[Music]
wish what are you hiding nothing
and nobody what is going on in there
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign